il fait beau mais si bol qui vendent ce
sont des commentaires reçus ce matin que
si ce mot n'est pas dit est-ce que les
phénomènes comme cela on pourra voir
plus souvent car même si évidemment
toujours la question construit j'ai vu
qu'il y avait moins de vent aujourd'hui
le je regarde le pauvre petit à leur jeu
fera encore
une deuxième journée de vie du produit
il vend tellement c'est un type
tellement fort on dirait que s'acharne
sont noirs tels que je prenne un peu
trop personnelle mon réalisateur lui il
ya un pinceau faudrait que je fasse un
sondage pour ou contre le vent
bon ben voila tout croche dans ses
locaux
[Musique]
peut-être que je remarque des choses qui
n'ont rien de spécial parce que je
serais plus attentifs aux changements
climatiques mais d'enfance a rien à voir
toute façon tout le monde est un peu
obsédé par la mi temps récent peut-être
que je me pose trop de questions
[Musique]
quand il ya des orages les vins sont
très intenses il ya des arbres sont
déracinés des branches cassées voitures
endommagées des pannes d'électricité
l'halloween annulé
est-ce que
ça va gagner
la réponse est oui oui philippe gachon
je le connais depuis c'est sûr que sa
réponse doit être plus nuancé que je
l'avais rencontré il ya quelques années
pour un reportage sur les inondations
c'est un spécialiste du climat
les vents c'est quoi ben en fait c'est
ni plus ni moins que le reflet de ce
qu'on appelle les différences de
pression qui proviennent les différences
de températures plus les différences de
température sont marqués puis les vents
sont intenses
honnêtement on en a évidemment des vingt
ans sur la côte ouest côté pacifique il
y en a aussi beaucoup côté est en
particulier en hiver en automne on a
également faut pas l'oublier sur la côte
est ce ici en amérique du nord parmi les
systèmes les plus intenses de tout
l'hémisphère nord
pourquoi parce qu'on a des différences
de températures très forte entre le
continent qui se refroidit en hiver et
l'atlantique qui reste chaud si on met
les changements climatiques là
une atmosphère plus chaude ça veut dire
une capacité à avoir plus d'humilité
dans l'atmosphère et ceux liés à la
halle est exponentielle
tout ça peut se transférer en des
intensités de précipitations plus
important qu'il ait des précipitations
les plus intenses des orages plus
intense des vents associés plus fort qui
dit aussi une atmosphère plus chaude y
potentiellement les cyclones tropicaux
plus en temps qui dans le contexte du
réchauffement vont avoir tendance à
remonter plus au nord on l'a vu dernière
il ya quelques années même cette année
ont eu des 70 cm de neige en l'espace
d'une salle tempête
même si on aura une saison par exemple
de neige avec le réchauffement plus
courte ça ne veut pas dire qu'on n'aura
pas des systèmes qui vont nous apporter
plus de précipitations de neige et des
vents associés plus importants mais les
régimes de vent sont à l'origine de la
plupart des pannes d'électricité qu'on a
ici au québec
mais j'aurais plutôt parié sur le
verglas faut absolument que j'aille leur
parler bush père philippe
ça va et
ben oui ça va très bien ok du moins
est-ce qu'ils vont beaucoup par chez
vous aujourd'hui l'oeil il va pas encore
super foule moi je pense s'en vient
et je manquais mon arrivée mais ici
aussi ils vont quand même pas mal je
sens décembre 2021 il ya 400 mails
abonnés d'hydro-québec qui avait manqué
d'électricité à cause des vents violents
tout le monde se souvient de l'automne
2010 9 la fameuse halloween qui est
annulé lost et près d'un million de
foyers qui avaient subi des pannes j'ai
pas l'impression que le vent ses deux
meilleures amies d'hydro-québec
dont on fête le vin puis d'autres aléas
climatiques ou si ça nous est pas que
c'est sûr vraiment le risque prince
passe sur la fiabilité notre service la
principale je reste les pannes qui sont
causés par les forts vents qui ont fait
retomber de la végétation sur les fils
électriques vous en avez peu plus dans
les dernières années il ya une grande
variabilité on l'isolé nombre de pannes
par année puis des fois cédé des bonnes
années par des moins bonnes années de
peindre présentement ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que nous sommes sont super robuste
vos installations sont sécuritaires par
contre un contexte de changement
climatique là où il ya un pack qui qui
nous attaque tic tout ce qu'ils nomment
de conception de nos bâtiments sont deux
des bâtiments qui sont là pour durer
longtemps dont les longues durées de vie
donc nécessairement qui sont impactés
par les changements climatiques
maintenant mais aussi éventuellement et
les normes de conception de ces
bâtiments le sont basées sur des données
historiques
[Musique]
par exemple on électrique on va
s'assurer qu'ils résistent à un vin qui
survient une fois à chaque cent
cinquante ans mais là on se base sur des
données observées le danger c'est que si
nous donner de vin augmente dans le
futur c'est que nos normes de conception
seront plus suffisantes
et puis nous on veut s'assurer d'être
prêt par contre le pot voir incluant les
données il nous faut des beaux projets
de recherche qui vont nous aider à avoir
une donnée aux bus devant un contexte de
changement climatique
on a cofondé ouranos fait que ça fait
vingt ans on a une démarche commune
concertée tout le monde ensemble en
attendant ce qu'on fait c'est quand on
planifie en conséquence et quand on
parle d'événements extrêmes c'est
tellement vaste moi je trouve si souvent
utilisée a trop largement parce qu'il ya
des zones vont être plus affectée il y
en a d'autres qui vont être moins
inquiet ça sera pas égale partout on ne
sait pas comment le vent évolué mais la
certitude qu'on nous sert on sait qu'on
est vulnérable au vent par contre les
tempêtes et les orages tous ceux il ya
plus d'énergie de disponible pour
pouvoir voir des tampax ont un peu plus
intense donc on peut pressentir qui va
avoir des vins qui sont plus intenses
aussi
[Musique]
on
bon on connaît quand même assez bien les
régimes de précipitations on peut
anticiper les événements extrêmes plus
fréquents mais si on prend les vents
moyens les modèles et nous devons
secours en lien avec les changements
climatiques pour l'instant ils nous
disent pas grand chose en termes de
tendance claire mais là je te suis déçu
philippe parce que le vent on l'a dans
la face depuis la nuit des temps chaque
jour le vent moyen là on n'est toujours
pas capable de dire si les changements
climatiques vont avoir une influence là
dessus l'incertitude est élevée pourquoi
parce qu'on n'a pas encore atteint une
résolution spatiale suffisante pour être
capable de bien générer ses ventes ça
veut dire par exemple quand on parle le
système de très grande échelle on est
capable quand même d'avoir une certaine
prévisibilité sur ces phénomènes là mais
dès lors qu'on parle de phénomène à très
fines échelles une tornade une tornade
ces quelques centaines de mètres de
diamètre c'est très peu grand ça n'a
rien à voir et puis grand système qui
nous apporte de la neige qui ont des
milliers de kilomètres mais pour être
capable de reproduire correctement une
tornade dans un modèle ça prend une
résolution très très fine pour être
capable de représenter ces phénomènes
l'un qui sont extrêmement ponctuels dans
l'espace tout ça est complexe mais on ne
peut pas pour l'instant anticipé
complètement les changements tant et
aussi longtemps qu'on n'a pas des
modèles sophistiqués et qu'on n'a pas
aussi une idée claire de comment le
réchauffement va se produire et ça ça
dépend de quoi de nous
[Musique]
ça dépend de nos activités humaines qui
vont influencer les degrés de
réchauffement les seuils de
réchauffement et le changement
climatique affecte et affectera les
régimes de vent des positions où vivent
les plus intenses situe
ce qu'on sait c'est que passé n'est plus
garant de l'avenir nous allons faire
face avec le réchauffement le changement
climatique lé phénomène qu'on n'a jamais
observée par exemple dans nos régions on
pourra se fier de moins en moins aux
statistiques passées pour savoir comment
le futur va être au delà d'un
réchauffement de 1.5 de gré ou de 2
degrés nous avons non seulement des
phénomènes qui vont augmenter en main en
terme d'intensité de fréquences mais on
va faire face à des phénomènes qui
historiquement nous n'avons jamais connu
si nous atteignons le 3 ou 4 degrés de
réchauffement
nous n'avons jamais eu de crime a aussi
chaud depuis dix millions d'années
nous n'étions pas là y'a 10 millions
d'années et l'être humain ne peut pas
résister tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
partout sur la superficie planète à un
climat le 4 degrés plus chaud enquête
ils disent un peu que je devrais
peut-être apprécié le vent qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est
oui il faut se préparer à des lendemains
difficiles mais les solutions existent
il faut je pense passer de ce qu'on
appelle la gestion de crise on est
toujours à intervenir ou à attendre dans
les moments c'était vrai pour la
pandémie mais c'est vrai pour la
météorologie il faut être capable de
deux semaines dans un mode proactif
il faut trouver une façon de nous
développer sans pour autant tout le
temps empiéter sur l'environnement
détruire notre biodiversité qui nous
fait vivre nous avons une planète une
bulle planétaire il faut la préserver
halo et royaume c'est encore moi vas tu
aurais pas un truc pour apprendre à
vivre en paix avec le vent par hasard
ou stoppa la bouche en marchant si c'est
premièrement aussi citer pressaient avec
le vent s'étant mènera au plus vite
mais le vent dans le dos que cette
poussera dans ton avenir